Let's talk a little bit about what
exactly a commit is. Now,  we talked
about to commit being a snapshot and
that's exactly what it is. A commit  is
represented by a 40 character sha-1 hash and I wrote a couple little short versions
over here but in that 40 characters
there's a lot more than just numbers and
letters. There is a blob of the changes,
so blobs represent files, so you made
changes say to index.html, Git stores a
blob of that file which is a reduced
version of that code in a very
lightweight way. It also includes some
metadata. That means who made the
commit,
what time did they make the commit, and
what's the parent commit? Now what's the
commit that was made right before this
on this working branch. All that
information is stored and compressed in
that 40 characters sha-1 hash, which
means that commit ID is very, very
important.